you know with each passing decade
betty's career just seemed to get better
and better but the 80s really were
golden
thank you for being a friend
i've read the script and just flipped
about it and b arthur and rooney
mcclanahan both have the same reaction
do you know what i hate doing most after
a party trying to find your underwear in
the big pile
these aren't old people you don't
self-destruct once you pass 55. we're
all just as as vital and sensual and and
uh
nutty and good and bad as anybody else
stan came by and stayed with me brought
me food held me
showed me that special part of himself
right there in the waiting room
do you know what a privilege it is at
this end of a career i mean after being
in the business this long to work with
three people no matter what you throw
out you get something wonderful back to
back why rose nylon why that cake is in
the shape of a blanch we know what it is
i thought it was in the shape of florida
can you believe betty was the eldest of
the golden girls she played the sweet
but not so sharp rose
my father told stan that he had to marry
me i was pregnant
you had a blow gun wedding
well this season uh we're writing the
other girls out and rose is doing it in
one it's just going to be you know the
betty white show and then
sorry about that no that's the real
betty coming forth you see rose has
disappeared
you know it doesn't matter whether i win
i mean just being nominated is enough
that's a good attitude rose it's also a
croc a bull i want that sucker bad
betty won her third emmy for the golden
girls in fact every single actress won
during the show's seven year run
now everybody on the golden girls has a
as a golden girl of her own i think
now next year we're all up for grabs we
start all over again isn't that
wonderful
do you want to see my vans cap kaka as
long as i don't have to show you mine
i've been so blessed it's such a great
experience
[Music]
come on man you've been riding me all
day you're playing like betty white out
there that's not what your girlfriend
says
betty white snickers super bowl spot in
2010 will go down as one of the best
commercials of all time but it's not
just betty's comedy skills that made
fans fall in love with her it was also
betty's love for animals
everybody said what would you do if you
weren't in show business well can you
tell what i would do
[Music]
everybody says when did your love of
animals start i always say in the womb
betty said if she wasn't an actress she
would have been a forest ranger or
zookeeper
these little guys nobody realizes that
pigs are among the smartest animals in
the world if you could talk to him what
would you say
i'd say that this is the way i love to
feel fur
this is the way it should be don't come
in all excited and talk to an animal
because you'll scare him to death just
keep your voice low and your voice calm
and your your hands firm but gentle you
don't want to start this business you
want to and you also don't want them to
comb your hair i think that's a little
much don't you
back in the 80s betty was an et special
correspondent for a series on celebs
with their pets including her own how
about down here come on around here
honey but getting three dogs and a cat
to behave for our camera was not an easy
task oh get those ears up for every
cattle
person in the world to know you're not
happy
this is tk
this is timmy and this is cricket and
this is dinah my retired guide dog
golden retriever she spent time with
tippy hedren and her big cats bo derek
and her horses and the tonight show's
bandleader doc severinsen and his family
of dogs and cats there you go to aunt
betty
didn't she a beautiful thing though
she's lovely and that's tough for a cat
to let a stranger take her and as for
the reason she loved her furry and
feathered friends so much they just give
you such comfort and they ask for so
little and you just they kind of keep
our priorities sorted out when
the planet is being paved over and the
noise factors and all the things get
louder and
more crowded you can kind of look at
these guys and realize what it's really
all about
as much as betty adored animals it was
her husband alan ludden who captured her
heart forever
who knows
it might be better than the first one
[Music]
love of my life when you've had the best
who needs the rest why betty white my
alan london well it's nice to see you
again nice to see you their love story
began on the game show password where
alan was the host what are your plans
for the summer miss white oh dear i'm
taking
no fool like an old fool i'm taking
singing and dancing lessons that's where
i met my husband and that's where we got
married it took me a year to get smart
to marry allen when he kept asking
practically from the beginning and i
kept saying no no no for love came just
in time
i found you just in time
[Music]
we went to dinner
and he gave me this beautiful wedding
ring with diamonds all around it and the
gold wedding ring and of course as any
red-blooded american girl would do i've
got mad because i kept saying no i won't
no i won't marry you and i gave gave it
back to him well did he take it back to
the jeweler no he put it on a gold chain
around his neck so every time i saw him
there was that blinking wedding ring he
said you're going to wear it someday you
might as well get used to it
so sure enough after after a year i i
did the ladies celebrity and password
this week is a lady that i married four
years ago today happy anniversary betty
white
allen was actually betty's third husband
she became the loving stepmother to his
three kids and chose not to have
children of her own no i've never
regretted it
i
i'm so compulsive about stuff i know if
i had ever gotten pregnant of course
that would have been my whole focus
but i didn't choose to have children
because i'm focused on my career
and
i just don't think as compulsive as i am
that i could manage both betty cherished
every moment of her life with alan who
after nearly two decades together became
sick from stomach cancer we knew for
almost two years that we were on a
dead-end street but
we just made up our minds that we were
going to make the most of the time we
had and as a result we didn't spend
a lot of time beating our breasts and
saying why is this happening
and we just
you can't handle anything well all the
time but for the most part it worked
pretty well
allen passed away in 1981 but betty told
us he always remained a part of her i
swear
he
somewhere in here he'd tell me you gotta
you gotta keep going and you gotta you
know shape up or ship out
and uh
he's still so very much around i swear
he's sitting in this chair
betty never remarried but over the years
she did develop a pretty heavy crush is
there one thing out there that betty
white still wants to do
robert redford
robert redford robert redford robert
redford i would be so embarrassed if i
ever met him
oh he never calls he never writes i
tried
he just never responded can't imagine
being loved by anybody better
[Music]